Monsieur François Noël buffet pour le
groupe Union pour un mouvement populaire
que le président ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Intérieur la semaine
dernière le Sénat a rejeté le projet de
loi rebaptisant les conseillers généraux
en conseiller départementaux et
modifiant leur mode d'élection c'est
incontestablement un camouflet pour le
gouvernement qui est d'autant plus
remarquable que ce n'est pas seulement
l'opposition sénatoriale qui a combattu
c'est très forme puisque tous les
partenaires de votre majorité les élus
radicaux écologistes ou communistes ont
mêlé leur voix pour empêcher l'adoption
de cette réforme ils l'ont fait parce
que celle-ci constitue une atteinte
grave à la représentation des
territoires ruraux dans le seul but de
favoriser électoralement les membres
d'un parti politique en l'occurrence le
Parti socialiste
après vos déclarations d'amour aux
collectivités locales mais vous savez
quand la matière il n'y a que des
preuves qui doivent être données on
aurait pu espérer que votre gouvernement
aurait formulé des propositions pour
accompagner la décentralisation pour
améliorer les conditions d'exercice
toujours plus complexe des mandaloks au
lieu de ça deux mesures majeures la
première vous avez préféré matraquer
financièrement les collectivités locales
au moment du vote du budget faut-il
rappeler que vous avez ponctionné de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble de celle-ci à présent vous
voulez modifier les règles électorales
des élections locales à la seule fin
d’être de tenter d'empêcher l'inévitable
sanction dans les urnes de la politique
qui est actuellement menée par le
gouvernement les galaxies des femmes et
des hommes aux mandats électoraux est un
objectif légitime que par ailleurs nous
partageons bien évidemment mais il doit
être poursuivi sans que cela ne se fasse
au détriment d'autres objectifs aussi
légitimes comme le pluralisme et la
représentation de tous les territoires
de la République
sous couvert de la parité vous avez
inventé un mode de scrutin que le monde
nous envie sur mesure pour vous-même et
sans équivalent au monde dans le seul
objet est d'affaiblir la représentation
des territoires ruraux dans certains
départements la taille moyenne des
cantons pourra dépasser 75000 habitants
en coupant ainsi tout lien entre l'élu
et ses administrés dans mon département
celui du Rhône les cantons feront 64000
habitants en moyenne dans le nord de
celui-ci la fusion de si cantons au
minimum sera nécessaire pour constituer
un seul nouveau un seul canton couvrira
un tiers du département
à présent que le Sénat dont le rôle
conféré par la constitution et de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales de la République a rejeté
ce texte il serait de toute évidence
contraire à l'esprit de nos institutions
que votre gouvernement persiste dans ce
aveuglement bien sûr et tente de passer
surtout en force à l'Assemblée nationale
un projet de loi sur les collectivités
territoriales contre la vie même du
Sénat et pas n'importe quel avis puisque
y compris des voix de votre majorité se
sont mêlés pour ce rejet dans ces
conditions-là personne ne veut de votre
réforme de votre réforme pardon et cela
a été démontré nous vous demandons de
retirer clairement ce projet de l'ordre
du jour et de représenter une autre
copie si tentée que vous le souhaitiez
qu'il soit plus conforme aux intérêts de
nos territoires et singulièrement des
territoires ruraux merci merci Monsieur
Manuel Valls ministre de l'Intérieur
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur buffet
prolongeons donc de quelques minutes les
32 heures que nous avons passé ensemble
sur ces questions un débat d'ailleurs de
très grande qualité avec des
préoccupations
exprimées par les uns et par les autres
il y a eu un vote c'est un contestable
ça n'est pas la première fois et on peut
le regretter à l'instar du président
rebsa même ce matin mais en tout cas moi
ce que je constate c'est que même si le
texte n'a pas été
voté et donc à ce stade il ne s'applique
pas bien évidemment au-delà des lectures
qui sont prévues le Sénat cependant
adopté des mesures qui me paraissent
importantes la suppression du conseiller
territorial il y a une majorité au Sénat
pour cela c'est pour ça qu'il faut
continuer parce que de toute façon il y
a obligation
le report des élections départementales
et régionales en 2015 ou encore les
nouvelles règles pour l'élection directe
des conseillers communautaires une
élection démocratique c'est d'abord une
élection qui permet à la société d'être
correctement représentée le scrutin
départemental doit donc être strictement
paritaire et c'est l'objectif du
gouvernement qui peut se satisfaire
d'avoir uniquement une représentation
des femmes qui représente 13,5% des
conseillères générales qui peut admettre
qu'il y ait deux ou trois départements
qui n'est aucune femme et puis en même
temps
nous ne voulions pas présenter un
scrutin qui soit strictement
proportionnelle parce que là aussi ne
permettait pas une bonne représentation
des différents territoires qui composent
un département et puis de toute façon
s'il fallait modifier s'il fallait
rester pardon au scrutin actuel il
aurait fallu un découpage c'est un mode
de scrutin qui existe depuis 1801 alors
je veux bien croire que vous soyez
attaché au consulat moi aussi pour un
certain nombre de mesures prises à
l'époque par Bonaparte mais en même
temps il faut vivre avec son temps et
donc son temps nécessite un certain
nombre de changements et la
représentation démographique elle doit
être claire elle doit être simple elle
doit être compréhensible par tout le
monde et donc la représentation
cantonale ne devra pas s'écarter de la
règle fixée par le Conseil d'État les
20% même si et moi je suis prêt à
desserrer cet étau on introduisant toute
une série d'éléments qui permettent aux
territoires
ruraux de la montagne nous en avons
parlé tout à l'heure bref à une bonne
représentation géographique de ces
territoires et je crois qu'on pourra
avancer là dessus voilà Monsieur buffet
votre major ité avait introduit de la
confusion entre le département et la
région ce gouvernement redonne sa place
au département vous ne teniez pas compte
de la population nous vous rappelons
qu'en démocratie un homme ou une femme
égale une voix vous aviez choisi un mode
de scrutin qui pénalise les femmes nous
nous mettons en œuvre la parité